collègue la lutte contre l'insécurité
est le premier des thèmes de la campagne
électorale ainsi hier à Strasbourg prise
à parti par une quarantaine de jeunes le
candidat UDF François berou a préconisé
la fermeté un reportage de Daniel
Sportiello et Nathalie
Bertier la meno une zone sensible de
Strasbourg les vitres de la maison de
quartier viennent de voler en éclat au
moment même de la visite de François
baayerou et du maire de Strasbourg
fabianne Keller vous vous rendez compte
ce que c'est euh la nuit si si en plein
jour se produit des incidents comme ça
de l'Ave générale il est urgent
d'abréger la visite mais François Baou
décide de descendre dans l'arène et
d'aller affronter les jeunes qui se sont
réunis devant la maison de quartier
moment de tension puis le dialogue
s'amorce sur fond de conflit au Proche
Orient PAL moi je parle de la France
mais
alors
France
sont des franç comme
toi ce sont des Français comme vous t
norm français
lui tu emploies des mots comme ça à
l'égard des Juifs demain on parlera
comme ça à l'égard des
musul le jour
jour des mots
injux et pendant que ce vif échange se
prolonge un enfant fait en douce les
poches de ou c'est la BA Françis Baou a
réagi diratil en paire de famille et il
n'y aura pas davantage d'incident une
heure plus tard devant une salle
archicomble à Strasbourg François Baou
va revenir sur l'insécurité dans les
quartiers sensibles il faut qu'en 18
mois ces quartiers voi de nouveau la
présence des forces de sécurité des
représentant de l'autorité publique de
ceux qui représentent l'état et la
solidarité c'est
l'engagement que je prends devant vous à
Strasbourg François baayrou d'ordinaire
consensuel à durcilton à Strasbourg sur
l'insécurité un tournant dans sa
campagne sachez